Hello, welcome to Michael's Better Business English.
This month, we're looking at how to persuade people.
Now, I'm sure this is difficult in Japanese as well as in English.
However, here are three techniques to help you persuade people effectively.
First, logical technique.
Now here, when we are trying to persuade somebody logically,...
...we give very clear reasons why they should accept our argument.
For example, we often use data, figures, statistics to support what we're saying.
For example, "Over 80% of our customers prefer this design."
"That's why I recommend it."
Secondly, win-win approach.
This one stresses the mutual benefits:...
...the benefits to both parties.
For example, "Now this option is good for you and good for us."
Third approach is the emotional approach.
Here, you're trying to persuade by playing on the feelings of the listener.
For example, this could be through sympathy.
"Oh, you know how hard I've been working recently."
"That's why I need a bigger bonus."
Or through empathy, when they understand your situation.
For example, "I'm sure you had the same difficulty yourself when you joined the company."
"That's why you understand my situation."
So, when you need to persuade someone, remember these approaches.
Often combining two or even three approaches,...
...that will really help you persuade people more effectively.
Thank you and good luck!